guten morgen aus kopenhagen wir haben
gerade eben drei stunden auf einem
parkplatz geschlafen
ein bisschen durch die stadt gefahren
haben uns überlegt was machen wir hier
sieben uhr früh um halb sieben
aufgestanden dann haben wir gesagt okay
wir fahren zum hauptbahnhof tauschen
bisschen euro in den jacko mumbai
dänemark ist ja die währung dänische
kronen nicht euro das haben wir gerade
ihnen gemacht außerdem haben wir uns am
bahnhof noch auszudrucken geholt also
ich hab mir eine figur dar in welchen
kaffee tag denn her
vancouver das alexa spitzen kaffee jetzt
ist es halb neun
wir wissen eigentlich nicht genau was
wir zu machen heute es regnet hat ein
bisschen in kopenhagen sehr schöne stadt
und sehr sehr schöne frau noch mann sagt
immer den schweden nach sieben so gut
aussieht aber dass dort auf die ideen in
den pdf die denn in denen leute eine
frage wieso kommen sie so cool
war jetzt gerade durch kopenhagen es
regnet umsehen das auto geschnappt und
bin jetzt eine kleine runde chance
bisschen um wir gucken jetzt ein
bisschen darum bittet weiter besser wird
oder auch nicht
vielleicht noch länger sein können
jackman es ist jetzt zwölf uhr 34 ich
hab gerade wieder eine stunde im auto
geschlafen
nachdem ich bisher um gefahren bin habe
ich gesagt okay jetzt wechselt plätze
ein bisschen müde leg dich hin
adrian ist irgendwohin gefahren und
schon während er früher bin ich
eingeschlafen sein irgendwo parkt haben
wir beim schlaf jetzt aber aufgewacht
gerade sind wieder am copenhagen
hauptbahnhof in einem starbucks hat mir
jetzt gerade noch meinen ersten kaffee
des tages wohl dokumenten ersten das
obwohl es schon halb eins ist und wir so
wenig geschlafen jetzt gerade haben
eigentlich bock jetzt gerade das andere
aufsaugen linke hat ein bisschen rock
aufzusteigen wir wollten nichts gegessen
übrigens da was die richtig gutes
internet finnwal download 2 abflaut ist
eigentlich echt gut für public internet
ohne locken kann man wirklich machen
plus 103 durchrechnen und wir sind
fündig geworden wir mit den laden
entdeckt im vorbeilaufen was richtig
krass ist hier gibt es einfach sushi
platte die wurde angeblich von 1000
kronen auf 500 reduziert ihr bis zu 1000
sind einfach 140 euro für eine solo
platte müsst euch geben immer noch 70
euro sei schnell klar dass unser thema
pack mas
so leute so shears findet die rechnung
ist sehr knackig muss man sagen ob das
dach komplett der trip der geschenke
einiges an geld als ich jetzt mal
richtig geiles so schien es war genial
riesige portion sehr lecker großes stück
kommen
es sind wir jetzt auf dem weg zu unserer
unterkunft dass es wie bereits
angesprochen so ein landhaus circa noch
eine halbe stunde
wir haben jetzt 15 uhr 41 und um 16 uhr
11 kommentare
so damit wenn wir hier in unserer
unterkunft angekommen das ist richtig
schön jetzt einfach auf dem land da dass
unser nachbar
so sieht das aus hier richtig cool und
wir wohnen hier
gehts hier drüben
und hier sind so zimmer schläft jemand
bisschen unordentlich so hier drüben ist
dann auch das bad noch sehr sehr sehr
nette gastgeber hier nach heute abend
vom nach kopenhagen reihen des ungefähr
40 minuten
hier noch ein bisschen feiern wenn
gestern zwei studentinnen kennengelernt
die meisten heute abend würde an einem
gewissen ottawas gehen irgendwo eine
party
das muss man erst mal frisch machen noch
zwei stunden kennen und dann geht's
wieder reinkommen ein paar sekunden
später bieten jetzt red i zum ausgehen
es ist 20 uhr 32
wir wollten eigentlich um zwanzig vor
sieben aufstehen haben dann natürlich
wieder verpennt wie das so ist wenn man
so wenig schläft ist nun für die nacht
aufgewacht weil der wecker nicht geweckt
hat den ich gestellt hat scheinbar war
ja auswahl weil ich eine gemeine
verschwörer den angemachten sicher so
ich stecke jetzt mal kurz warum unser
quartier verlassen wir jetzt wir begeben
uns nach kopenhagen reisen auf diese
eine spenden party der wasserlauf
heutigen block und ich würde eher im
ende internet eintragen
da